and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bomb
tonight's review the Dark Knight
oh my god this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life baby Jesus
there's this guy called Batman only he's
emotionally tortured and psychologically
toured in this clown called the Joker
only he's not a very funny clown he is
freaking crazy and not like hey that
guy's crazy I mean oh he's uh he's
legitimately insane and there's a nice
woman called Rachel only things don't
work out for her it's uh kind of hard to
talk about right now and there's a
District Attorney Harvey Dent and she so
the Joker makes a video only it's not a
funny video he is slowly torturing
someone to death I think I suddenly
remember why I'm afraid of clowns
I mean bozo is funny but this clown is
not here's a psychopathic clown with
deep psychological issues who looks like
he put on his grandmother's makeup world
and so Batman twice to stop the Joker
but so many people die in the process
and he has to ask himself what does it
mean to be a hero and at what point do
you stop being a hero the responsibility
is just holy jelly beans Batman no no
look it's the Joker let's defeat him
with our sound effects
pow BAM boom the deme asleep again
thanks to Batman but nobody is safe in
this movie everybody has a price to pay
I have a price to pay I have an
obligation to myself and to all humanity
and all it took was a man to blind bat
suit to convince me of that this movie
made me question the morality of mankind
forever
I think I'm gonna go home to my box said
think about the responsibility that I
have to the world and I recommend that
you do the same this is Chester a poem
saying you know what keep the change